[Music]
last call make it a double I did the
office a lot of booths such a small
woman I don't get asked something on a
second date in my line of work you got
to know when to walk away but some cases
just won't let you go Jessica Jones
you tossed a man twice your size across
the ball with one hand Donnellan kicked
in
does anyone else know about your
abilities there's one another out there
his ability of us to make people do
whatever humans step forward me like my
control Jeff you want to do it you know
you did exactly
you'll have to face them alone yeah I do
[Music]
how will you prove that this mind
controller is real George I'm a private
investigator
I'm resourceful
a couple words and you're his weapon no
one else will die because of me
Pilates
I could kill you right here right now
what you want because you don't know
what will happen when I die
[Music]
[Applause]
drinking short fuse
mess all I have is my professional
reputation
Jessica let's stop
I don't know how you handle it it's
called a whiskey
hey youtubers it's Charlie new Jessica
Jones footage the series is gonna all
drop in less than 10 days so let's break
it down the fun thing about this trailer
is it just reveals way more David
Tennant it actually implies that if
Jessica Jones were to kill him something
terrible would happen like he had some
sort of final kill order that he's
implanted in everyone it seems like
they've tuned everyone's powers down
just a little bit like Jessica Jones can
fly in the comics but she's not gonna be
flying on the TV show the purple man can
affect like a great number of people but
they have to be in certain proximity to
him so if he were to walk into the
middle of Times Square in the middle of
a giant parade then yeah I mean he would
be able to affect the ton of people at
the same time but because his powers
tied to pheromones like a biological
pheromone that he gives off it's
something that stays in your bloodstream
that's why even though when we pick up
an episode one she's already escaped his
clutches she still hallucinates him
there's still a lasting psychological
effect and there's probably a little bit
of his pheromones that are stuck running
through her body the longer you're
around him like the deeper his
pheromones will seep into your body so
as you can see in the flashbacks in the
trailer Jessica was used by him to
commit crimes for a long period of time
in the comics it was several months I
don't know if it's gonna be the same
amount of time on a TV show they might
play with that a little bit then it
looks like jeryn hogarth here who works
for Rand Meacham in the comic books is
the one that hires Jessica Jones because
the purple man encroaches on some of her
business interests or some of their
business interests Rand Meacham is the
company that Danny ran iron fists family
owns there are a lot of iron fist rumors
going around so I'll have to do an iron
fist video at some point they're still
going to be doing something with it the
rumor is is that Netflix has seen the
footage of Jon Bernthal is the Punisher
like they've been filming daredevil
season 2 and the belief is is that
Netflix likes what they see so much that
they want a green light a Punisher
series before they do iron fist and just
because Punisher fits a little bit
better into this D powered world of the
defenders iron fist starts to take it to
this like crazy mystical territory in
right now daredevil still in crime drama
mode that Jessica Jones is the same
thing too it's not at all like the world
of the Avengers where you have like
really fantastical stuff happening and
that's kind of where iron fist gets to
but I don't I don't think that's a big
problem I think they're just having a
hard time finding the right director the
right actors the right cast and they
already have this Punisher
guys so they're like okay well we have
this sitting on the bench right now so
why don't we greenlight him first so
it's totally possible that we can see
like a full Punisher 13-episode series
and then like a short two-hour Iron Fist
movie and he would still be in defenders
it's not like they're not gonna do any
Iron Fist stuff they just might change
their objectives a little but the cool
thing about that is is that it just
means that Punisher is so awesome that
they're bumping him up the batting order
speaking of big hitters Mike Colter was
actually talking a little bit about Luke
Cage it sounds like he will have his
powers when this series picks up what
Jessica Jones picks up but the bigger
idea that I think this Jessica Jones
trailer conveys is that she's kind of on
the outs she's all about working by
herself she needs to learn to work with
a team and Luke Cage is a big part of
socializing her again here's the big
question though let me know in the
comments would you rather see a
13-episode Punisher series you know just
like daredevil and Jessica Jones before
iron fist and then like a two-hour Iron
Fist movie or would you rather see 13
episodes of iron fist and then a
two-hour punisher movie either way
they'll all make it to defenders and I
think of all the characters Punisher and
daredevil have the best chance of making
it into the movies daredevil is just the
most fully formed character they have
right now just because they've had an
extra 13 episodes and we're just getting
to Jessica Jones but I think what's each
character gets their first season you'll
start to see them popping up and a bunch
of other stuff no promises on Captain
America Civil War I think you know
daredevil maybe small chance of being
mentioned during Captain America but
there are already so many characters in
that so I'm not gonna hold my breath and
if it wasn't cleared the Captain America
civil war trailer is gonna be attached
to Star Wars The Force awakens and they
just announced that x-men is attaching
their x-men apocalypse trailer to that
too so you'll have two giant trailers
dropping with Star Wars I guess that's
gonna have to be enough to get us
through the holidays to January when TV
comes back Deadpool is actually opening
the year in terms of big superhero
movies just because that comes in
February I think you guys are really
gonna like the Stan Lee cameo in that it
was actually it was in the Comic Con
trailer so if you were at Comic Con and
you saw it you probably know what Stan
Lee is doing but I think they cut it out
of the public trailer that they released
online there is some new Star Wars stuff
coming on Thursday but is dropping
during ABC's primetime lineup and it's
all like you know female-oriented TV
shows so it's probably going to feature
the female characters of the force
awakens a little bit more than previous
trailers
we should be badass I'm hoping for more
captain phasma will talk about that more
on Thursday night so be sure to
subscribe to get everything just in case
you guys haven't seen my flash vs. zoom
video from last night you can click here
to watch that and you can click here for
my Marvel playlist with all my Jessica
Jones videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you